die sterne
seit jahrtausenden faszinierend wie
menschen und beeinflussen angeblich auf
unser leben
zum jahresende sind die zeitschriften
und zeitungen voller horoskope und
astrologische ausblick auf das neue jahr
jedem der zwölf sternzeichen ordnet die
westliche astrologie typische charakter
eigenschaften zu ein bisschen kann ja so
die krone eigenschaften eines menschen
glaube ich schon dass die im haus kubach
sich widerspiegeln finde es ist immer
ziemlich ablesen was nicht zutrifft und
heute eigentlich nicht wirklich was
davon
ich lese es wirklich fast regelmäßig
also ein gewisses im unterbewusstsein
dürfte so ein gewisser glaube dass er
nicht nur kurz kuppel polarisieren das
weiß auch gerda rogers allzu gut
das sternzeichen der österreichischen
star astrologin ist der steinbock die us
cent eine weitere komponente des
sternzeichens die mit geburts zeit und
ort zusammenhängt ist skorpion
so verbindet sie bodenständigkeit mit
einem handschuh mystic sagt die
73-jährige die astrologie ist für mich
ein absolutes zähle der menschen hinein
zu blicken anlagen tendenzen zu erkennen
natürlich auch die zeit qualität zu
erkennen wo der mensch gerade steht
ich finde sie astrologie ist absolut ja
eine gute entscheidungshilfe bei
situationen bei mitteilungs fragen der
rogers schreibt horoskope für
verschiedene deutschsprachige
zeitschrift und zu besonderen anlässen
schaut sie auch gerne die sterne des
stars so sagte sie unter anderem den
sieg von conchita wurst beim eurovision
song contest 2010 voraus
auch als lebensratgeber ist astrologie
gefragt zu mir kommt jede alterstufe es
kommt jede jeder berufszweig ob mann ob
jugendlicher also es gibt hier überhaupt
kein tabu mehr
natürlich kann ich beobachten dass sich
durch die wirtschaftskrise das ganze ein
bisschen geändert hat jetzt kommen mehr
männer
da geht es um große wirtschaftliche
themen weil der wirtschaftliche erfolg
in der heutigen zeit ein ganz ein
wichtiges thema ist wissenschaftlich
belegbar ist die astrologie nicht
doch auch wenn es viele nicht zugeben
mögen die sternwarte reihe übt eine
anziehung aus laut einer umfrage aus dem
jahr 2012 halten mehr als 5 prozent der
deutschen viel von der sternenkunde 33
prozent immerhin etwas in österreich
glauben über 50 prozent an ihr horoskop
forum 30 jahren eröffnete gerda rogers
in baden bei wien eine praxis für
astrologischer lebens beraten ab 50 euro
kostet eine persönliche sternstunde
mit einem speziellen computerprogramm
erstellt sie aus dem geburtsdatum der
zeit und dem geburtsort ihrer klienten
eine astrologische bild dann beginnt
ihre eigentliche aufgabe die deutung des
bildes mal im moment wo der mensch jetzt
gerade steht in welcher situation in
erster linie seine ganzen anlagen
ich kann jetzt genau erkennen wo hier
die kranke stelle ist bei meinen rat zu
händen und wenn ich das natürlich
erkenne kann ich auch zu gleicher zeit
wieder lösungsvorschläge machen die drei
sterne
rogers und sylvia graf seit mehr als 20
jahren berät gerda rogers in einer
radiosendung hauptthema der anrufe die
liebe abend du kennst den andreas jetzt
seit fünf jahren gemeinsam mit
moderatorin sylvia graf bietet sie rat
für wichtige lebensfragen an andreas
kopp an die fische dame mit waage aus
zement
natürlich es sind enorme sympathien
vorhanden er ist aber prinzipiell ein
mann wo ich sagen würde es sowieso
absolut bindung scheu auf nun
wissenschaftlich belegt oder nicht viele
interessiert natürlich wie wird das neue
jahr werden
ich sehe 2015 als ein positives
wandlungs jahr speziell ab der zweiten
jahreshälfte wenn sich der jupiter in
die jungfrau schiebt im trigon zu pluto
steht dann bekommen wir wieder stabilen
boden unter die füße und sehr viel
lebensfreude
das sind gute aussichten und spätestens
in einem jahr wissen wir ob gerade
rogers richtig gelegen hat